the atheists are are saying that the
biggest threat to the country is
Christianity Christian extremism this is
according to a website called atheist
Revolution gearing up for 2024 they say
atheists and non-christians should have
among the highest voter turn out of all
why because of how much we stand to lose
when Christian extremists gain power we
should vote like our lives depend on it
because they do this isn't about
upholding abstract principles or doing
the right thing it is about our survival
if we want to have a future we need to
expand our efforts to oppose Christian
extremism to which I say if you don't
like Christian extremism just wait until
you see unchristian extremism because
it's going to be a lot worse and you're
going to be longing for the days of
Christian extremism